[Musique]
je m'appelle zachary poulin et je suis
un cinquième homme je suis passionné par
l'aviation commerciale
j'adore voyager je pratique le ski le
vélo de montagne ainsi que le taekwondo
lors de cette présentation
j'aimerais vous parler d'une initiative
que je trouve extrêmement est enceinte
et qui vise à aider de jeunes musiciens
comment et s'agite projet joseph bonjour
avant de débuter
laissez moi d'abord poser une question
très simple
avez-vous oreilles et bien sachez
qu'elle la réponse à cette question
pour avoir un impact direct sur votre
succès scolaire en effet il a été prouvé
que les jeunes c'était ça qui ont des
aspirations pour le futur démontrant
plus d'engagement envers leurs études et
obtiendront donc de meilleurs résultats
scolaires
le projet joe rise a été lancée en chine
il ya sept ans par des gens d'affaires
ce projet vise à aider enfants à mieux
réussir dans ce schéma scolaire
c'est une partenaire d'affaires de ma
mère madame à l'esa qui lui a parlé de
ce beau projet dans lequel elle
s'implique activement
j'ai moi même eu la chance de rencontrer
alice qui via hong kong
car elle nous a déjà visité à la maison
c'est une personne très généreuse et g
impliqué dans sa communauté
d'autres études danse et des professeurs
26ème et minteuan également de
l'université en vol ont démontré
l'importance de se fixer des bus et des
intérêts par exemple la recherche a
démontré que les élèves de deuxième
secondaire qui ont des rêves des mondes
plus de motivation aux études donc hors
eau de mer résultats scolaires une foire
aux aux 5e secondaire une autre étude du
professeur marc albert qui a démontré
que l'espoir est un sentiment que les
possédants seigner et qui représente un
élément essentiel
un tragique thouars de vie réussie
premièrement les élèves sont d'abord
invités à remplir un questionnaire afin
d'évaluer quelles sont leurs rêves leurs
aspirations et leurs êtres est
malheureusement ces questionnaires ont
démontré que 30 pour ça des élèves
étrangers à hong kong ou en chine
n'avait malheureusement pas de but
précis pour leur avenir le projet vise
donc à envisager les ce qu'ils
aimeraient faire plus tard ou ce qu'ils
aimeraient accomplir ensuite bien sûr il
faut voir les moyens à prendre afin d'
hervé accomplir leur rêve aussi le
projet rise vise à présenter aux élèves
des carrières d'avenir dans plusieurs
peuvent ignorer l'existence
par exemple on y fait introduction à
l'intelligence artificielle qui consiste
à développer des appareils capables de
simuler l'intérieur semaine à la
technologie bloc chain ou chaîne de
blocs en français qui consiste en une
technologie de stockage et de
transmission des formations dans
l'application fort et c'est des crypto
monnaie mais qui pourrait s'avérer la
bosse de multiples autres applications
dans le futur et au développement
informatique
finalement des conférences y sont
invités à présenter leurs expériences
personnelles aux élèves ils peuvent
ainsi il leur montrer que si on a un
objectif on peut le réaliser
tourné en ma question des ports en ce
qui me concerne la réponse est claire
mon plus grand rêve est de devenir
pilote de ligne et jeux le fournir tous
les efforts nécessaires dans mes études
afin d'y parvenir j'espère que ma
présentation a permis de réaliser
l'importance d'un mauvais rêve
et qu'en travaillant fort pour reste son
objectif tout est possible
[Applaudissements]